hey let's go French lighting is fair oh
yeah yeah
welcome to Paris Jesus not a purpose
welcome to poser to Paradise Lost it's a
dlc of a game that came out [ __ ] 12
years ago and the game is kind of
questionable and a game itself it's kind
of like a mod already so I would say not
to offend the Craters of course but I
would say this is a DLC of a mod that's
12 year old 12 years old that came out
today I don't know what the [ __ ] just
happened
you can select difficulty libre mod -
easy very easy easy real medieval and
say no they hate me postal impossible
all right well I'm a pro and movie
probably bro so me for that so I'm gonna
select I'm gonna select very easy thank
you
check animal control and eat alright we
need to ask about champ check animal
control and eat alright I got a shovel
what's up gonna dig these holes out if
you know what I mean
excuse me sir have you seen this dog
have you seen this lost dog strange give
you some thoughts conclusion where are
you running you see in this world has
two kinds of people my friend
I was with loaded guns who dig Hey
here have some of mine Abel juice the
Nabal juice is not resurrecting him
let's ask more general people of this
city holy [ __ ] I know have you seen this
adorable pooch recently well why are you
writing
don't run have my needle juice have my
navel juice it's free come here and have
my navel Jos all right now you will have
my navel juice yeah ma'am come back at
once good are you gonna offer [ __ ]
sake none of my shows they're brand new
probably thought you were gonna die
today Jesus right let's go and eat it
says this way to the mall do we need to
go through them all no I don't think so
[ __ ] where you running skills made
there what do you think about the dog in
this photo yeah what do you think about
it Wow dare you speak to Edgar this way
apologize apologize that's right
okay I won't hurt you what the [ __ ] you
he killed himself that's not my fault
say he's dead don't cry Jesus Christ
stop crying how many bugs you son navel
juice it will make your hair grow sure
stroke what happened I blacked out I'm
sorry was that fun land
well it ain't so fun now is it yeah
alright animal it's animal control this
way thank you animals are people too
they're doing a great cause now to save
my dog hello that says control center
and pets what can I do for you have you
find this yeah I'm searching for a herd
of ostriches and wide for about 17 years
who said that no that's not it
I've been searching for my lost dog you
should check the kennels in the back
it's just around the corner past the
elephant cage no for [ __ ] sake
you keep an elephant and in its nice
sideburns I said nice sideburns mad dog
can it yes perfect all right let's see
here nope alright I think that one is
dead
alright no that's not right [ __ ] cats
in here
nope not him no that's not champ what
the hell is that supposed to be well I
don't know then they're just a bunch of
[ __ ] fairies oh that's good job
Bessie open those fairy cooper's oh okay
then I'll go this way
gray here have a scissor free scissors
always presented himself for me thank
you sir preciate it
Simeon's why did you get that gun are
you Steven Steven what are you doing
don't kill them if they die there get
killed
it running though I don't insane no
kitty No
or they will all pay for this
no one cares my kitty but move oh it's
on now isn't it it's on four key all
right pay for what you did for kitty how
dare you kill an innocent little kitty
what turtle kitty
oh my favorite restaurant
Caucasian grand reopening come and taste
our great new meat I got a bad feeling
about this bass you better tell me right
now what you know about this dog or I'll
follow you home and kill your dog
you should go speak to the wise man he
knows all around these parts
the wise men what someone actually held
an enlightening if I were to see this
wise man you don't like my neighbor
choice it's a number two they will use
what everyone Hey hey girl you like
their neighbor dude all right I'll have
the mr. meat excuse me you're sending
the [ __ ] the way all right
what are you doing let me spoken head
guy already well I guess that adds some
meat to the menu
what happened
what all right now we just need to speak
to the wise man no big deal the hell's
our problem it's coming from my navel
it's coming from a neighbor it's coming
from a neighbor
hence his navel juice mmm I love me I
love you and I especially love neighbour
juice wise man will drink my navel juice
watchman is drinking mini ha beeps
Oliver ignore me yeah whoa
Oh gasoline [ __ ] gasoline girl gasps
leave girl I a Sally girl [ __ ]
gasoline girl guys with a girl kitty
come here kitty kitty kitty kitty kitty
kitty
watch this yeah now that's what I call a
silencer
you okay there kitty okay then kitty
let's get giddy you're my best friend
kitty your kitty Roy what how dare you
say that about you don't know me kitty
what is this
this way to them yes I can read kitty
my god ah cutie one here bites man hey
wise guy I am looking for some
information
why is he
[ __ ] you're not just talking to a wise
man you're talking to the wise Wang huh
you have entered the domain of crisis a
wise Wang long think we drank an energy
drink or something
jumbo kitty around oh gosh I'm sorry kid
I was just testing to see you work
shut shut your [ __ ] mouth kitty
you're racist biggest [ __ ] look I'll
get it can I get double kitties oh my
god please come here
come here kitty kitty kitty come here
kitty
it's your fault what did you do no candy
no here [ __ ] don't you know anything
about animal rights alrighty then we're
gonna end the first episode right there
I hope you enjoyed it was a lot of fun
we did a lot of weird [ __ ]
but anyway leave a like if you want more
of this series I can do one day each I
don't know that'd be cool I'd love to do
that so let me know in the comments and
thank you for so much watching click
here for next part and I'll see you in
the next video see ya damns I did my
salad dancin now and that was it well
this is the most realistic prison
simulator I've seen him a left and I've
been to prison I've seen that [ __ ] up
close all right well let's yeah